the damage to Ukraine's massive novocal
culture dam is one of the more dangerous
events in the war so far this is why
the targeting of the dam has been
apparently on Russia's agenda since last
November December when the ukrainians
moved into the Western Bank of the NEPA
River it was always anticipated that if
they were under real pressure they might
blow the dam flood the downstream area
and make it much harder for Ukrainian
forces to cross onto the Russian side of
the river
the damage located at novakovco just
north of the settlement itself it's a
very big Dam very important and it dams
the mighty NEPA River as it flows South
towards the coast and very importantly
it provides a lot of water for
agriculture which is critical to that
part of Ukraine
the impact of blowing the dam is first
of all humanitarian because it will
flood the uh the valleys and the
downstream area and that flooding will
build up in the next 24 to 36 hours
depending on how low the water goes in
the reservoir that depends on how badly
the dam has been damaged around the top
a second issue is the zaparizio nuclear
power plant which is about 100 miles
north further upstream and if zapparesia
goes short of water for cooling then
there will be a major nuclear incident
now we're not there yet and the iaea the
atomic Watchdog is not too worried about
that at the moment but they're keeping a
close eye on it
this is a potentially dangerous moment
in the war because it represents a
scorched Earth policy on the part of the
Russian so in other words the Russians
are affecting the area around the dam
that are affecting the economy of
Ukraine and the welfare of an awful lot
of civilians for a military Advantage
simply to create a bigger barrier for
the ukrainians to have to cross if they
want to move across the river nipra and
attack them and so this is an example of
of War becoming a civilian problem and
being visited on civilians and for that
reason of course whoever committed this
act of the dam committed a war crime
the significance of the dam to Crimea is
that the What's called the north Crimea
Canal comes off the waters just above
the dam and 200 million liters of water
a day flow through to Crimea and Crimea
takes most of its drinking water from
that Reservoir so if the reservoir sinks
to very low levels the people of Crimea
800 and 800 000 of them or so of whom
are Russians who've moved in there they
will go shorter water this summer and
maybe go without water if the reservoir
drops to very low levels
officially the Russians have claimed
that this is all Ukraine's doing I find
that very very hard to believe because
Ukraine has absolutely nothing to gain
from doing this and some have even
suggested it's the result of artillery
fire and that's absolutely ridiculous
because you really can't damage a dam
like this with artillery shells and this
has been created by explosives powerful
explosives that have been placed right
against the wall of the dam quite near
to the top so the idea that somehow this
is just War damage is just not credible
this is a deliberate Act of sabotage by
somebody and the only somebody that
makes sense is Russia in actually
committing the ACT which they have been
threatening to commit since last
November